last year for the first time since
tracking began in 2000 the average
american house earned more than the
average american worker that sounds
pretty strange but it's true and in some
places the gap was pretty large i want
to talk about what that means explain
how this climate may be affecting
sentiment and confidence and look at how
rising wealth may not be providing its
usual effect in terms of making u.s
consumers more confident about the
economy what does it mean that houses
made more than workers last year the
median u.s home rose in value by 19.6
percent in 2021 an increase of nearly 53
000 from 2020. the median u.s full-time
worker earned a little more than 50 000
in 2021 and that was before taxes this
unprecedented happening is a combination
of three things the cost of housing
being very high to begin with the
significant increase in the price of
houses and the fact that workers wages
aren't keeping up here's why this could
be hurting consumer confidence prices
for homes groceries and gas are rising
at a faster pace than americans pay and
that looks to be weighing on sentiment
and confidence even though nominal wages
and salaries rose by 4.5 percent the
fastest pace since 1983 they failed to
keep up with inflation in fact after
factoring in cost increases for the rest
of the economy americans wages actually
declined by 2.4
so the average consumer actually had
less buying power in 2021 than they had
in 2020 even though they got paid more
we're seeing the effects of that in
confident surveys and slowing spending
the university of michigan's consumer
sentiment index for march was the lowest
since 2011 and in the preliminary survey
more households expected their finances
to worsen than at any time in the
history of the survey which dates all
the way back to 1970. this suggests we
may be seeing a change to the typical
wealth effect americans wealth rose to a
record 150 trillion dollars in 2021 an
increase of more than 8 percent from the
end of 2020. that was largely due to the
increases in the value of housing stocks
and other assets like cars
usually when wealth rises sentiment does
the same it's called the wealth effect
even if folks can't touch their
increased wealth because it's tied up in
their house or their 401k they get more
confident but we're seeing a bit of a
breakage in that pattern it may have to
do with the fact that wealth is being
concentrated in fewer and fewer hands
the wealthiest 10 percent of americans
own around 90 of all u.s stocks
according to the federal reserve and a
recent survey from the national
association of realtors found that
high-income households own around 43
percent of all housing wealth between
2010 and 2020 those wealthy households
gained 71 percent of the increase in
housing wealth but beyond inequality it
seems like there's some interesting and
unusual things happening here and i want
to hear from you you know these things
are all about people and i'm interested
to hear what you people think so drop a
line in the comments let me know what do
you think is going on why are we seeing
a reversal or at least a change in the
typical wealth effect that we've seen
demonstrated over
generations
leave me a comment let me know and be
sure you also like and subscribe to keep
up with this conversation and topic and
all things markets and the economy i'm
reminded of 21 savage who said back in
the day i invest in the block fast
forward now i'm invested in stocks i'll
see you next time